les magasins de bricolage qui relance
une nouvelle fois le débat autour de
l'ouverture le week end demain mardi 14
mai le collectif les bricoleurs du
dimanche ambitionne de faire défiler
jusqu'à 2000 salariés dans les rues de
paris
objectif obtenir un décret pour les
magasins franciliens en ligne ludovic
souley bonsoir à vous oui bonsoir vous
êtes salarié d'une enseigne de bricolage
aux clayes-sous-bois responsable pour
les bricoleurs du dimanche du secteur
paris ouest de l'enseignent castorama
aujourd'hui quel est l'enjeu derrière
cette ouverture du dimanche pour les
salariés également peut-être pour les
clients pour le secteur en général deux
du bricolage
donc il car bien sûr on va pas vous le
cacher il ya un comment dire un acquis
monétaire qui pas négligeable pour nous
ça permet aussi de faire travailler tout
lajnef qui se trouvent en ile de france
une bonne partie des qui de financer
pour la plupart leurs études
ça reste quand même un bien essentiel et
o'shea 2 par rapport à la vie en ile de
france de la part de nos citoyens qui
vont travailler du lundi au vendredi qui
vont se retrouver pas automatiquement
comme beaucoup de personnes c'est à dire
le samedi on fait les courses
alimentaires et le guide revanche on
s'occupe de son intérieur de la
décoration et on vient donc dans les
magasins de bricolage en cas de maintien
de cette interdiction et même peut-être
damon très dissuasif pour les enseignes
de pour maintenir ces ouvertures le
dimanche vous pensez qu'on peut assister
à une disparition d'emplois aussi
peut-être je pense à ces étudiants par
exemple à tout à fait tout à fait bien
sûr je vous cache pas si jamais
éventuellement les magasins de bricolage
en ile-de-france sont doivent fermer le
dimanche va donc les chiffres du chômage
au augmenté de manière très conséquente
il ya plusieurs syndicats tout même
qu'ils sont aussi contre cette ouverture
du dimanche par exemple force ouvrière
syndicat qui a obtenu 4 millions d'euros
de castorama qui a fait également faire
condamné bricorama à une amende record
de 37 millions cette dernière semaine
vous leur répondez quoi alors à londres
qu'il n'a pas été versée ils ont déjà
fait quelque chose qui tient à préciser
parce que j'ai donc été revu baby dont
moi je suis plutôt un petit peu choqué
parce que quand tu veux entendre par les
syndicats ou j'entends même force
ouvrière je parle du profil peut donc
que c'est des personnes tuées à la base
soutiennent et aide les salariés dans
leur combat et leur force ouvrière
explique retrouve force ouvrière qui
explique que justement l'ouverture le
dimanche c'est un petit peu on va dire
ce qui fait courir les salariés pour
obtenir une rémunération plus élevée il
n'y a pas d'augmentation pour ceux qui
travaillent la semaine par exemple avec
éventuellement cette possibilité
d'arrondir les fins de mois en
travaillant le dimanche ce qui aurait
préféré force ouvrière c'est de revoir
les salaires avec une ouverture sur la
semaine
oui bah moi d'un moine au genou gilles
rennais parce que voilà moi je trouve un
avantage c'est à dire avoir des vous en
semaine je n'ai pas d'obligation
particulier au niveau du dimanche ça
reste encore une fois donné par car je
tiens à préciser voilà on est vraiment
si on est autonome on décide de
travailler le dimanche et personnels
couteau sous la gorge ni oublié on ne
veut pas on ne vient pas travailler donc
disponible on vient il ya vraiment aucun
problème
le ministre du travail michel sapin qui
rappelle que dans le commerce la
fermeture dominicale est la règle
l'ouverture est l'exception c'était pour
la déclaration de son cabinet est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment de pouvoir être
entendue avec cette mobilisation de
demain ça ne sent pas une priorité du
gouvernement
enfin pas une priorité du gouvernement
peut-être faire mais je construis qu'une
couronne où nous allons être entendu je
pense je pense car nous avons on a quand
même un petit peu quelques contacts au
niveau au niveau des hommes politiques
je ne vois pas pourquoi mais car en plus
c'est un combat qui pour moi encore une
fois est légitime c'est à dire que je
n'ai pas le souvenir au niveau de
manifestations autres bacs des gens bien
dans la rue justement pour aller
demander le droit de travailler merci à
vous je rappelle que ce collectif
bricoleurs du dimanche sera dans les
rues parisiennes demain mardi pour
demander un changement de la loi et pour
continuer refermer à cette séquence je
vous propose un autre micro trottoir
êtes vous pour ou contre le travail le
dimanche vos réponses en fait je suis
contre le travail le dimanche parce que
je trouve que c'est une journée qui
devrait être consacrée plutôt à la
famille des activités qui sont non
mercantile en fait il ya suffisamment de
jours comme ça dans l'année pour pouvoir
consommer pour pouvoir faire ses courses
moi qui étais dans le commerce or à dire
pendant 20 ans
ça a du court mais ça a dû contre non
clair je saurais pas vous dire en toute
honnêteté en tant que salarié je ne
travaille pas le dimanche mais il serait
possible effectivement gens violent très
envisageable de travailler quelques
dimanches mais pas tous les dimanches
qui joue effectivement le jour du
seigneur le jour du repos domaines
suivants 1 restauration je suis plutôt
pour parce que les gens droit de sortir
que ce soit du lundi au dimanche après
il ya des métiers où il ya peut-être pas
une nécessité de travail comme dans
l'administratif pour nous en tant que
client une ouverture le dimanche c'est
que positif